all right dude okay all right okay go
ahead all right my pick is about one of
the key figures behind the scenes of the
movie
judas and the black messiah the film's
up for six oscars
at this sunday's academy awards
including best cinematography
it is the first nomination for
american-born
sean bobbitt who's based in britain
here's the extra cool part
he started his career as a cameraman for
cbs news
back in the 1980s when we worked
together
out of the london bureau how are you my
oscar-nominated old friend
i'm not that old am i
[Laughter]
no not not to me you're not no the black
panthers
are forming a rainbow coalition of
oppressed brothers and sisters
sean got his oscar nod after director
shaka king
asked him to shoot judas and the black
messiah
the drama based on the true story of the
killing of black panther party leader
fred hampton this level of injustice i
mean a state-sponsored murder in the
united states of america
of yet another black man um is
you know it's shocking
[Applause]
addresses a rally after he's just been
released from prison
liberate him you can't murder liberation
the angles that you use on daniel khalia
on that scene
they're deliberately kind of low aren't
they yeah
daniel kaluuya has that power
it's all there in the performance
but by just dropping below the eye line
a little bit
it enhances it in a very subconscious
and subtle way
it was shot in a single day in a
cleveland church
that's a lot of pressure to put on
yourself for such an important scene
well you know and this is where my news
background has always held me in good
stead
no one's gonna shoot at me no one's
gonna try and kill me
so it's like there's no pressure
for nearly a decade back in the 1980s
sean was a freelance cameraman mostly
for cbs news do you miss those days at
all of being shot at
i did for a long time it was hard yeah
because adrenaline is a drug and you get
used to it
and you crave it sean traveled to the
world's hot spots
and shot scenes like these in beirut
why did you give it up it was becoming
more dangerous
a lot of friends had died you know and
i'd also always said to myself
you know if you stop crying at the
horrors that you see
then you really have to go and i had
stopped crying
and i thought well wait a minute you
know i
there's no point in losing my humanity
sean started
in documentaries then in 1999
landed his first feature wonderland
steve mcqueen ends up seeing that movie
with his wife and after
the film's over his wife turns to him
and said you should be working with that
cinematographer
so thank you bianca that's how it all
started
he went on to shoot mcqueen's first
feature film
hunger about irish hunger striker bobby
sands
in 2008 they've made
three more films together
including 12 years a slave oscar winner
for best picture
in 2013. one of the things i've noticed
in your films is
as a viewer you're rarely conscious of
the camera
that's the highest compliment you could
pay me the camera must
must not draw attention to itself
otherwise you're drawing the audience
out of that world
and and they think it's a movie
my queen shawn has also shot occasional
television dramas
i want to pay myself including the pilot
for game of thrones
surely the dead can wait but you didn't
want the full-time gig
my soul would die you know i i
need to be moving on i need to be doing
other things
even at home he's on the move sean lives
on a houseboat
outside of london but on the lone star
ii which flies the flag of his native
texas
sean bobbitt slows down
the speed limit on the river is five
miles an hour
and the world becomes such an
interesting place at five miles an hour
are you enjoying the attention and
adulation that comes with an oscar
nomination
no no i'm a very quiet person
i'm i'm much much happier the other side
of the camera
well we'll enjoy it for you then and i'm
so rooting for you you may be
underwhelmed but i'm so impressed
then sean had one last thing to add
i've got a dreadful admission and i need
you to forgive me
um in the early 80s at a barbecue at
your house
i borrowed a bruce springsteen album and
i never gave it back
and it has been oh that was you it has
been haunting me
for almost 40 years so please just
forgive me i'm not going to give it back
but i just kind of need closure
if you win all is forgiven
[Laughter]
should have been like two oscars tickets
that's the price of that album
i know oh my god i i remember the party
i i don't remember
losing the album so it's all is forgiven
but i'm so
excited for sean it's such a huge
achievement
you know and i'm excited for i hope his
parents are watching in san diego ellen
and john
uh your kid has turned out real well
when was the last time you spoke to him
i i haven't you know it's funny he said
people have reached out to me i haven't
talked to in ages because of this i
literally i was reading the oscar
nominees and all of a sudden i saw that
name and i was like i know that name
and i called deb thompson who
runs our uh london bureau and i said is
this the same sean bobbitt and she said
it is
and uh and so then i reached out to sean
and he was like i'm hearing from folks
you know i haven't heard forever so
such a wonderful moment for him even if
he's underwhelmed himself such a happy
guy
congratulations sean yeah exciting
exciting